Tastes bugs. They come into the mic, talking about the food.
They hate talking about the food they like to, fool's gonna fate,
but only one food Temby rate, taste buds, man. Didn't come into them.
I come shock and say, taste birds.
He's a sweetie pies. It's a taste buds. Yeah.
The show where me and this guy debate food. Yeah. I mean,
if you, if you're watching, if you're new to taste buds where the buds,
where the bud, you see the, the name is very Woody. You see,
we went through dozens of choices and we thought taste buds.
We debate foods all the time. When we hang out and with fervor,
with VIM and vigor, we debate, am I right? Yes. We're passionate about it.
We don't mind. We will have we, Oh,
what an ideal day for us would be is if we have an exchange of dialogue,
will we just really dig in and, and go over the minutia of something? Yes.
Over and over. It's how that, it's how we are wired. Yes.
And it happens all the time. And a lot of times it happens with food options.
And so here we debate food.
We put the Twitter poll out at the top of the episode, we pick a side, um,
it's, it is based on what we feel passionate about.
So we're not just arguing for arguing sake here. Right?
That's a big caveat that I don't know if we ever mentioned,
it's gotta be something that we disagree on organically.
And not that you hate the other item, but hands down,
you will die on the Hill of the item you're defending versus the other item.
Yes. A hundred percent, a hundred percent.
And sometimes you do hate the other item. Yeah. Sometimes you don't, but, uh,
these are real food debates we've had in private and now we're bringing them
public. Uh, and then at the end of that, at the end of the episode, uh,
these are like fun little half hour episodes. We, uh,
have a segment called humble pie where we go to the polls and we use the polls
as the, be all end, all answer to, uh, to the debate that we're having. And,
uh, you know, the person who loses seats a little bit of humble pie. Right.
Right. Even though they're still right. We'll be like puns.
We'll be like food puns.
We were leaning in hard to the foodies buds pie pie. I'm sure.
We'll come up with more. Yeah. Something great. We're going to start getting,
yeah, that was one of them too. Yes. But taste buds was perfect.
These spreads is, I mean, we should, if you have them in your phone one day,
is it like a little thing we should read all the things you may be.
We're going to call it. Oh yeah. And then wait. No,
my phone's charging or another. We'll do another one. Yeah. Um,
so today's Throwdown. Yes.
This is a big one. This is what is the best traditional.
Hi. Hi, traditional Apple, not Apple crumb. None of the Chrome stuff.
Just regular, straight up Apple pie versus regular,
straight up peach pie pie. Uh,
I predict right out of the gate that this is the first episode of taste where I
will walk away. The Victor Sao has foolishly
chosen peach, peach pie.
I stand by it ever since I'm little. I have nothing against Apple.
I really gotta be in the mood for Apple. I think it's overplayed.
I think don't listen. We didn't start the poll yet. Don't waste your sorry.
I wish I was going in hard on the app. Don't waste your. Jesus. He's already,
he Hickey better pie. Traditional Apple, traditional peach.
And that's a tweet right there. It's out. It's out. All right. Now,
go ahead with, let the game nauseousness, you were just spewing, you know,
few things in my life where you just about to say I'm sick, Apple pie.
Would you just read it? Yeah, I was gonna really,
but then I decided to explain to you what I mean Apple pie. I don't hate it,
but I had to be in the mood for it. And it is delicious when made, right.
Especially with a scoop ice cream hot, but again,
we're not adding the bells and whistles.
So you're talking about a slice of traditional occupy on its own and a slice of
peach pie on its own.
There are a few things in my life that I can name that I've had that I used to
love. And then I ate them so much. I got sick of them and I,
I'm not saying that had more Apple pie.
I didn't eat Apple pie until I got sick of it.
But Apple pie is around so much that I am sick of it. It's just like,
don't get me wrong if there's no other pie. And you're like,
do you want a nice hot slice of alibi? I'll be like, I have it. You know what?
I find a lot with Apple pie. I'll take a bite. I'll take two bites.
If it's not Chrome or doesn't have any other bells and whistles.
I tap out after a couple of bites.
It's a little too much of that Apple saucy.
I extended really to the Apple. The Apple is the culprit.
I'm I was never a big Apple fan my whole life.
I think the apples are a little too pungent, little too sweet and tart.
And I take a bite of an Apple and I chew and I go, no, I get it. I get it.
I get it.
An apples close to a pair and a pick and take a and jump over a bridge.
A pair is terrible, but anyway, um, like pairs, a pair,
I think is the most overrated fruit ever in existence. No,
that's the cantaloupe is the most overrated. No way. Cantaloupe is great. Okay.
Mark it down. [inaudible]
I'll smash it for fun. I won't even put it in my mouth. Okay.
I've never seen someone purchase a pair. Yeah.
That's already been in the market with me, the whole other episodes show me
and we just write it down. So the thing about the Apple pie is like,
it's always the go-to pie as well. Like my, I think conversely,
one of the best fruits ever made the swans.
I mean the fruit of all fruits is a peach.
When you have the right peach,
a ripe beautiful peaches better than a perfect Apple,
it really is a peach is succulent juicy, bursting wood flavor,
citrus notes. It just live in just tastes buds. Your senses.
It is invigorating. I love it. I love peach in my ice tea.
I love peaches. Peach is I as, as,
as versatile as an Apple is I think a peach is nearly as versatile with none of
the credit. Uh, granted my favorite dish is more of like a cobbler or whatever,
but I will tell you peaches, aren't always in season,
it's a treat to get a peach pie. Uh, everything,
a peach represents just a juicy, beautiful peach.
I feel like it's a summery thing.
Now I know Apple pie is America raw.
Like I know the speech you're going to give it because it's it's,
it's like a hug from your mother. Just like the cinnamon raisin Vega.
I that's not what I was going to say.
What I was going to say is a peach in its pure form is everything you
described it as.
And then somebody takes it and cuts it up and ruins it by putting it into a
hot mess of a thing. It tastes a peat up the Apple.
Apple's a different story.
I'll take a peach over an Apple off the tree any day of the week.
Interesting. You cook those things. You cook those things.
You're in different territory. Now you want to talk about, uh,
to like everything you described as good about the peach is
lost in peach pie. You get none of that flavor and peach pie,
peach pie just tastes sugary.
It just tastes sweet. None of the layered notes of an actual piece,
where are you buying your peach pies?
Where are you buying your Apple pie that you're saying there's too much
[inaudible] in it or whatever the hell you say. And as I said, the Apple,
sauciness when you cut it, all that stuff, that's like, it's almost like the,
uh, like, like in those stuff, like every pie that like,
you ha you need this stuff to bond it. Like, yeah. Yeah.
Every pie has that stuff, but it's too happily for me. But every pie has that.
Every part I'm saying you got to be not the ones that's in the app.
Like the Apple on Apple is just, it's just too.
It looks like a lot of nice Apple. See like gunk in the middle of Brown gunk.
Look at peach pie, peach pie. It looks like it's not even like a real food.
By the time it comes out. Look out, look at the color of it. A peach pie,
a beautiful, vibrant peach pie with look at the color of it. That looks natural.
Unnatural. It looks orange. Orange is a primary color.
What are you talking about? It's Raji, Bev, Ritz,
the Owen Roy that looks unnatural, dude.
And that doesn't taste like peaches when you eat it. And you know, it,
it doesn't taste like punches.
This is a classic DeRosa move he takes.
And now he's shifting the argument to he's.
He's making you think that peach pie doesn't taste like peaches does he? Okay.
But I mean, for the, this, these purposes, a peach pie,
I'm talking about the tasting of a peach pie.
So you're going to take away the fact that my peach pie tastes like peaches,
how much it doesn't taste like beaches. I love canned peaches.
I love peach peaches. I love a SRE,
a fruit cocktail with the peaches in it.
Peach pie and peach cobbler are the only two forms of peach.
I don't, I love peach ice tea. It's my favorite flavor. Peach pie.
Listen to what he's saying. He chooses a peach off the tree,
over an Apple and peach is his favorite. Oh,
your favorite ice tea is not Apple peach pie and peach cobbler are the only two
flavors of peach. I don't like because they don't taste like peach.
Peaches are loaded with sugar. My friend that is not the natural peach.
I feel more like a pizza, but you get yourself. But we're both saying here,
pick your pick the bakery or the chef or whatever.
That's making the best of the best. I'm talking about the best.
Not like you had some peach pie that didn't taste like peach. I'm talking about.
Let's talk about the both pies,
the way that they should be presented at that Shelly's mess. It's disgusting.
Looking look at that. No, it's not gusting. Look it is.
That looks like gentle largess and there's little notes of red on the skin that
they left in there.
And you get these deep notes of red with these bright orange slices.
You want colors? Go look at a painting. I'm talking about flavor here.
I want to taste the pie. I want it to taste good. That looks nuts to me.
That looks abscond. And we're not even getting into a scoop of,
of ice cream and or a dollop of whipped cream. But if you put,
you don't want to go down that road, I would an Apple pie. It's on,
it's on menus and restaurants, all a mode. And you can add it to any pot.
With a dollop of whipped cream is way better on a peach pie than an Apple pie.
I said it and I stand by it. Who gives a? If you whipped cream can take a swim.
I don't care. I'm not rushing. All right. All right.
Well fine. But whipped cream for me stops at cool whip, Anthony. Cool with,
but I could care less.
You had the nerve in the last episode to say that everything bagel seasoning was
for trash people and you're telling me your whipped cream stops at cool whip.
If it ain't cool whip, you don't want any, I didn't say miracle whip.
That would be trash. I told her,
I'm talking about fresh made whipped cream and you brought up cool whipped,
whipped cream. I guess. That's cool.
If I have coop downstairs and I have already whipped and I love whipped cream,
but if I'm not having nothing has ever taken up more needless space on a plate,
this is when you're ready with, this is what you do. What you did this to you,
you applied, you applied the argument to the,
you denied me my argument for the Oreo.
And then you took that same thing and you applied it to the cinnamon
raisin bagel. You pick sides, you play the sides. And now,
now you, you play the sides
because you just said, what did you just say? I said, ready with miracle.
Whip is cool whip or cool whip. And you say,
you don't want to hear nothing when it comes to court, but then you had the,
you had the, I said,
nothing takes up more useless space on a plate than ready whip.
My point to you was,
you said the buck stops at cool whip with you who have cream. And I said to you,
you had the, you had the gumption. Yes. And you had the,
you had the sack to tell me that everything bagel
seasoning in a, a, in a jar is for trash people.
And then you told me the buck stops at cool whip was here and you're not playing
sides, no mango seasonings for trash people. I sent it my head.
They cool with it. I mean, cool up is if the light I, I'm not
[inaudible] against cool whip. A Coolup is where, like, when we grew up,
like you got cool whip and like, you were like, I mean, it's like, it's,
entry-level something, God blessed. You whip at you too. You're telling me,
you're telling me everything.
Everything bagel mix in a jar by trader Joe's is a
[inaudible] topic that it was only really put into the marketing.
It was only really put into the market. In the last couple of years,
it sells at a premium.
That is an item that is much more artisinal than a bucket of cream.
And you just get the bucket. Of course. Get your precious peaches on the right.
It does. I told you, I told you, let me tell you this. Let me tell you this.
This is how much I stand by what I said, cool website. Kool-Aid I like it,
but it's also on the, on the bottom of the rung of ladder.
Whereas in artismal thing, like an everything bagel,
I'm so confused by the clash of you having both in your kitchen downstairs.
Cause I know that you have depends on my mood.
I feel like I just went into a trailer in a trailer park and saw Rembrandt on
the wall. I don't know what direction this guy's coming from saying about you.
You, you have some nerve because you, you can't call everything bagel,
seasoning for trash people and then say,
cool whip is for the hierarchy for the foot. You can't say it's for the
populace of the multiuse. It doesn't work like that to be a rare commodity.
What do you want for me? It was, we're getting off you open Gatsby's about pies.
You open Gatsby's refrigerator.
You think you see an everything bagel seasoning first or bucket of cream,
a bucket of cooler. You crazy crazy.
Now I know you're not playing with a full deck. Cool whip before. Listen to me.
Okay, cool. Whip comes up in a search. Google.
It comes up with tag and pop rocks. That's a cooler comes up on. Cool up,
comes up next to, uh, the, the drink of our finance astronauts,
the brave man and outer space. I'm proud to see it there and next to pop rocks,
which I also consider it. See, can we hold on a minute?
Because we do say this is educational.
Sometimes the reason those came up together is the same guy.
William A. Mitchell invented all of them.
All your favorite trashy foods.
They call it trashy food.
And the title of the article I eat.
Sometimes it is a burden being described.
It is a burden. When you can pull up reports,
we're way off base here. We're way off top named Mitchell shout out.
Cause he invented tank cool whip and popper.
Yeah. I find Tang. Disgusting. I can't taste it. Take it or leave it.
That's funny. D also I find it's orange beverage. Disgusting. Yeah.
Yeah. Now, now let's get back to the pies. Okay.
You're telling me here's something. No human being has ever.
Said, especially in the United States of America, man,
you got peach pie. Nobody's ever said that. No, he's never been a diner.
Yep. Peach pie. I love you. But if this podcast is going to work,
you have to make arguments that make sense. You can't make a statement, Joe,
you can, I'm doing this now. I'm actually being your bud. In this situation,
you can't make a statement.
Like no one in this history of the United States has ever said,
do you have pinch pot? That's crazy. I've never seen it served after.
A meal. I've never seen it in a diner. Okay. And I've seen it.
I mean, I mean, I,
I can't wait till we disconnect and I'd tell you the last time we ate it because
we both, but I, I can't, I can't talk about it right now. Yeah. Yeah.
Cause it's, it's a sensitive matter, but it's okay. I'll I'll remind you later.
I remind you later on. I, you never seen it served. I guess I got new soil.
I got no sweat.
If I was anywhere and it was served. I said, what do you mean.
Get out of here?
I gotta be honest. If, if it's,
if an Apple pie is on a menu and there's also something like a key lime or a,
like a Boston cream or something like that,
I'll always go something other than Apple, Apple. It's like,
if you just have Apple, I'll have Apple, but I'm taking a key lime.
Even I even, even sometimes a lemon Marino.
I'll take a lemon. Marangu sometimes over an Apple.
It depends on what I'm in the mood for.
But if you're talking about throwing down.
You don't like peach pie. You don't like peach pie. You don't like it.
Hey. I mean every word about to come on my mouth. I mean, it,
it takes every element. I love about peaches and ruins. It.
It doesn't taste like peaches anymore. To me, what? It tastes like pushy.
Hi, sweet flavorless, kinder.
Fruit, Apple pie. You haven't had good peach pie buddies.
Apple pie is more reminiscent of a peach to me because of the tartness peach pie
has never,
every time I've had it or peach cobbler never has the tartness of a peach. Okay.
It never has the juiciness. It's all gone. It's all just hot.
And I, I mean that.
Not hot slop. And if anything, all pie becomes hot slop.
You can't assign hot slop to peach pie and not say that Apple pie is not hot
slop. Same thing happens with blueberry pie. Like, like you lose all the crunch.
You do lose a crunch in an Apple in a, in a, in an Apple pie.
I'm not there for crunch. I'm not sitting there for quite a talk slop.
It's just.
What is all the Brown gel? All that Brown gel substance. If you look at the.
Apples in these pictures, especially that one on the left with the,
I know it's a crumb one, but when the Apple is prepared like that,
that is a firmer.
Bite of pie. You know why I hate that.
So the apples are sliced thin and long ways for the slice those
long. See, now the one over there is the chunk I prefer.
Here's what I don't like about the way that you just as a slice one,
when you take the fork and you go down,
it shoots out from the fork and then you're not getting a proper.
But do you know why it shoots out? Because it's not mush.
I've never had peach pie where I got a firm bite of peach in my life.
If you're not eating there, listen, I'm not here to debate.
You know why I'm surprised you've eaten.
You know why I'm not eating the right peach pie? Cause nobody has the.
That's my point. Nobody.
Has never seen it on a menu in my life. That's Joe,
Joe, Joseph, you crazy. There was a diner.
And you know what though? Do you want like peach pie is again,
it has to be in season. And it also is like, yeah, it's,
it's not there all the time. It makes you want it to make you miss it. Apple,
Apple, Apple, Apple pie, everything. The most standard things in Apple pie.
If I saw many of the hat and Apple pie, I would be like, you know what?
This place can stand to be more creative with their dessert.
Call. And I saw audible here. I'll call night's auto. Take Apple out of the mix.
I still stand by it. It's what I said. I was throwing down with. Okay. Cherry,
cherry crushes, peach pie. I love a cherry pie. Okay.
Well then we agree on that.
Great. A question. I absolutely love you. Agree that it crushes the peach.
Well, hold on you think cherry? Oh, you don't think cherry crushes, Apple,
Apple Jennifer one, because I could have went up against you with three pies.
Cause my favorite three pars are peach, blueberry and cherry.
Blueberry. I would, I wouldn't walk.
I wouldn't step on up. I'll tell you right now.
I even only went peach now because I've been in a real peach pie mood.
But if you would have caught me in another day,
Sherry or I'm telling the blueberry might even blueberry might even be my
favorite pie.
Grand slam blueberry is the other pie.
I refuse the dead serious. I wonder.
Sound reason. None of the.
Wonderful tartness of blueberry to it. It just.
You're not the right pies. No,
I don't like that. I don't like that one. No, I don't like that one. That,
that one. I like, not that. Not that that, no.
No. That's nice. That's even, I love that.
I love when they do the weave to the basket weave.
Yeah. Blueberry pie looks like, it looks like when you go to a fancy restaurant,
the they drip around the actual food. Do you know what I mean? When they,
when they drip like red, like election around the food.
That's what blueberry pie inside.
Look at those beautiful blueberries. Are you nuts? Again? Apple is great.
It's beautiful looking car. You buy, you know what you do.
You know how you get apples? This there's so many apples.
We can stand to chop down half the Apple trees and we still be fine. You go,
you go with your friend, Apple picking. It's like 99 cents for the family.
Take as many as you can hold. That's how you do Apple picking. They're like,
please take the apples from the farm. Come on in. We're doing deals.
It's the whole family. Everyone take buck. They give you baskets in buckets.
They say, take as many as you can bring home. It's not a special fruits.
A blueberry is special fruit. A beautiful cherry is a special fruit.
Arguing. The value of a blueberry or a peach or cherry.
Value of the pie version off with the Apple enough.
It's a better blueberry pie is not.
Do you put a better example is not a better pilot American cheese on it.
Like a real garbage plate. Do you do that?
Put on what blueberry pie people do that, you know, American cheese,
you've never heard of this. People put a melted slice of American cheese.
Now they don't. I almost wear my own mouth.
So I swear on my life, people melt American cheese.
Blueberry pie.
They a hundred percent do that right there pie with cheese,
ancient tradition or an Alamo, but that's not blueberry. That's Apple
now that's peach. I think you could find out by clicking. Oh,
it is Apple. It is Apple, Apple milk, cheese on pie. It's disgusting.
That is gross.
It's disgust. I guess it's sweet. Savory. Is that the deal? It's disgusting. My,
my friend.
Blueberry pie. That's one of the reasons I always hated, but I mean,
it keeps coming up with Apple buddy.
That's uh, that's it that's I mean,
that's a crash single dropped right on top of your it's disgracing your pie.
It's hard. I mean, and by the way, with Googling, Googling,
blueberry pie, American cheese,
and only Apple pies are coming up.
Just because some animal put this block.
Cheese on pie should have cheese with fig and cheese with grape, you know,
like on a, on a platter. So I guess I good cheese.
Fruit is tremendous. Yeah, that's true. But,
but not like that, dude.
It's a different cheesecake is great. You might have to dabble in a little, uh,
marijuana and see if that works brother. I've had it. It's disgusting.
Really doesn't taste. Right? Cause he's a garbage person. He's a garbage person.
He's going to prove.
It through and through. That's how he is.
I mean, I I'm just letting you know a peach is a special fruit.
I mean Apple it's Apple juice. It's Apple cider. It's Apple.
It's Apple juice.
We've discussed an Apple juice is the best juice we've discussed it all my God,
please stop.
What I love. We've discussed. It nothing's happened. You love Martinelli's.
They take nothing away from the Apple juice,
but he just calls it the best juice. What do you think? Tops, Apple juice.
I mean a fresh squeezed orange juice. My friend Apple juice could take a walk.
Apple juice causes children's teeth to rot and fall out and they look weird.
You're talking about hacky and you're saying orange juice. There's a reason.
It's the best juice. There's a reason. There's a reason.
It's the reason Apple pie. Please Mark it down. Please Mark it down.
Let's go. Let's come back to it because you're bat. I'm not even,
I love Apple juice. I love it. But I couldn't have it every day. Orange juice,
crazy.
You know what I want to have with my breakfast now doing with now doing another
episode, we had to go back, hold on, just hold your, told your tongue.
I was like, worried. Like I was like, Oh,
are we going to find like more of a sense?
It's like coming out as we're doing these. I got, I got a lot to say juice.
Okay. No, but no, not now. No. I'm not going to hold your tongue.
Where are we a time Mike? Okay. All right. Let's let's go to the polls.
So we don't go over again and let's see where it's at because I want to have the
time to read some comments. So we'll say, I believe,
I believe that you're going to win this one because Apple pie is Americano and
it's all traditional and it's and it is, it is out there.
That's not right. That's a one vote, one vote,
but they did what the other guy did with the, uh, that he did the same thing.
The everything bagel guy did, unless we go, okay, here we go, babe.
Ooh,
hard to shake.
You to be hard to shake. This is like a bombing in front of your parents.
Are you? So you're about to eat humble pie. Oh my God.
Ooh. But I knew.
I knew it was five, but I want to see that's like saying Yankees versus like,
you know, don't you backpedal now take your medicine.
What was the number? 6,000, approximately 6,000 votes here.
So far you got to Apple.
86, 1486.
14 By a landslide. I mean, I knew it was going to win.
I think a wind by that much. Holy. But you're in America. Dude,
go to Europe and, go, go, go somewhere else and ask,
do you hear me make these excuses gloat globally as go, go hear these excuses.
But yeah, you're right. When I was in Italy,
they couldn't start talking about the peach pies,
but a baseball's America's pastime.
And so his Apple pie is associated with Americana. So I had no,
I knew I was never winning there. I didn't think it'd be 86, 14 Apple pie,
Apple tart.
The only place I've ever seen peach cobbler is in a Vegas buffet.
Hey, it's not a good.
You're insane. I'm not in it. Just because you choose to eat pie like.
He goes, peach pies are disgusting.
I had one at a Vegas buffet making my point for them.
I just go to your local, go to your local person who died,
who go to a dynamite pie. Point me to go to a pie, man. Do you want a pie man?
There's people. There's so many good pie places in the city. Listen to me,
I'm saying, I'm not saying I've only eaten from bake for face.
I'm thinking the only place I ever even come across it is it is at a buffet in
Vegas. Well, you, I don't know what you're doing with your life,
but go into a nice bakery in New York city.
The place where you live and don't pay,
don't pay seven 99 on Fremont street and complained to me about the,
about the quality of peach you're getting. Okay. I do wonder,
I do wonder if I would have went cherry or blueberry cause I could have gone.
I do wonder if they would've fared any, but I bet you had cherry pie.
I bet your cherry pie would have fared better. I might want to revisit.
I want right match. And I take a different pot.
You against cherry apples. My number one,
but cherry is so valid.
There has to be. The episode should have been cherry. What makes this cherry? I,
I, I should've picked cherry point is no, no, no.
I'm going to not be able to sleep tonight now because this was a,
this was a waste. I need it. I need contenders.
I'm saying we wouldn't have had an episode.
If you picked cherry part of what had been closer, might've been 60,
40 might have been by about a one.
The point is, is I don't dislike cherry in any way. I love cheese.
I understand. But I can't disparage it in any way. Whereas,
whereas I gotta be in the mood for an Apple. I also disparaged Apple. Yeah.
You had, you had a, you had a thing about Apple. You didn't like it.
It's like I'll eat it.
Oreo and I'll all over it. But you know, before I eat it though.
Yeah. You said you wouldn't cross the street, but I'm not always going to win.
I'm not always going to not cross the street for one. You know what I'm saying?
There's some cherry pie. You like, you just like Apple more.
So it wouldn't have been a kid.
I love cherry pie. I love Apple pie. Apple pie to me is the all time.
Great cherry is.
I'm gonna have a shot because if I would've chose cherry, we wouldn't have,
we wouldn't have, there would have been no debate. We're sitting here.
Two delicious pies. And you would have said the mean. You said about Apple pie.
And I would've said I can't insult cherry pie. I love it.
Now if you pick blueberry,
I would add even more to say that I said about peach because that's a.
You know, we'll read two comments.
I can't even read some comments.
Whoever says peach should be arrested.
Okay. Well I'm just going to write back. Well all alright.
We got.
Uh, okay. The clear winner is Apple, but I can't stand a cooked Apple.
So it's peach for me.
Uh.
I love Apple pie, but only cold. I need peach for sample comments. People.
When we start looking at the podcast and you ever see the Twitter poll,
come out, please don't deviate and apply your reasoning to this. Just,
we want to hear your comments,
but you want to hear them about the singular two things that are going head to
head, please, please. All the buddies out there. The taste buddies please.
Good. We all right. We just named the audience. Uh, look at this,
this comment right here. I went.
With peach. That being said, I've never had peach pie.
That's how much she did tests.
Yeah.
But my sight unseen blinds. What the hell is peach pie?
Not a product that you find anywhere. It's my
peach pie is a pie.
Okay. Apple pie for sure. But peach cobbler, beats, Apple pie.
Any day I told you about the cobbler. I told you about it Apple,
but only because there was no peak can. Okay. I don't need that Apple pie,
but peach cobbler. There you go. So Apple pie, hands down. No question.
I chose peach, but typically peach comes in a cobbler form. Not a pie.
This is where I might've went wrong, buddy.
I should've put up peach cobbler against Apple pie. No.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. I could have done that.
Not pie cause there's Apple cobbler too. And I don't,
I'm not a big Apple cobbler guy. Either. Some guy wrote once again,
this isn't even close, but whoever said Pete should go to jail.
Uh, yeah.
Yeah, no, this guy look at this. Um,
you must go to Matta tuck long Island and try the peach
or any cream pie at this farm stand. You will remember it.
Bremer Briere Bree or mirror for your mere farms.
The winter, the winter response is this year.
Should we pick a winning response every week? We should. Should we do that?
And just call them out. We'll just give a shout out. So people have it like,
you know, and you've got to play by the game.
Rules though. That's the winner, right? This one,
she put the gift up from American pie when he sticks his finger in the Apple pie
and it sticks in it.
Okay. So that's kind of new set, new thing. At the end,
we are going to crown the best comment, uh, on this. And we will see,
we will call out your Twitter handle and, and call you out.
I will say little rules. It should be strictly about the comment,
a comment on one of the two things we did not like what you think that you would
do with another PI? Uh, no, it doesn't help to be. It doesn't help.
If it's funny, it doesn't not help. If it's like, what am I trying to say?
I think I'm having a stroke.
I know what you're saying. I know what you're saying.
Do you agree that that's the winner or no?
Uh, what the hell the hell is a peach pie?
I mean, what the hell is a peach pie is a great one to that.
That might be my favorite actually. I'm sorry to get the other person.
Real Sal, really peach. Be better. Peach SMH.
Shaking. My head.
Apple is overrated says this person.
Cancel the poll. All correct answers are in. And they did the 100%. Yeah.
Yeah. I'm not. I mean, I'm, I'm,
I'm having a hard time finding people to back me with the peach. Yeah.
It is getting kicked out of me. I'm having a hard time. Uh.
Wow man. It is getting.
Wow. This person says definitely 90% of these people.
Haven't tried my grandma's peach pie and there's a peach pie emoji. Thank you.
I mean, but again, it's this like,
it's this like completely tiny narrow window.
Like you've never had the peach pie.
The one person I know that makes it makes it's like, yeah, no.
You know what I mean? It's like, nobody's going, Oh,
the peach pie at Denny's is great. Nobody's saying it.
Again where you get your pie spice. You are the love cool whip.
And you like going to Vegas,
buffets and Denny's and then you take a on trader Joe's, everything, bagel,
seasoning, anything. I'm just going broad.
And just making a comment.
McDonald's most popular restaurant chain in the entire country.
You'll find an Apple pie. McDonald's you'll never see a peach pie.
House of pies was the name of a restaurant.
When I lived in LA that I used to go to every Saturday morning,
they never had peach pie.
Peach, Carla, we met. I mean, I really just, I'm not gonna be able to let,
I'm not gonna be able to sleep tonight.
As in anything other than Apple is just unAmerican. That latches onto me.
They're voting for America here. Not the pie. Uh,
answers are paid for big Apple has their hand in this poll. Let's big.
Apple has their hand in this poll.
Let's crown the winner. I think what the,
I think the hell was peach pie is the winner. Uh,
and that comes to us from Handel at reel.
On lyrical lyrical, R E a L.
U N L Y R I C a L at real unruly.
So get a favorite. There you go. We named it and I hearted. Yeah,
there you go. That's fun. I like that. Cause we want to hear it.
We want to hear your snide comment too.
When she gave him a retweet. Yeah. Okay.
No, I'm not doing that. Okay. That's fine. I don't know. I don't know how
we're liking and taking the handle. Yeah, that's good. All right.
That's our show folks. Oh, hold on a second.
Okay. This is Oh wow. Even now Neil, Brendan's getting okay.
This is the people our people are in. So that's it. Do you still,
I still love you, buddy. I love you too. Thanks for listening.
Tastes buddies, uh, plugs without a country, the podcast recurrent Fisher,
and I.
Discuss the news every week. Uh, gas, digital network, every Tuesday, Cubs,
the live stream. Every Saturday.
It hits wherever you get your podcasts all over the place. Uh,
and you can get a free 30 day trial over cast co promo code WAC
and, uh, Pat Walsh.
And I have a podcast called we'll see you in hell where we review movies of all
genres back catalog at Starburns media and wherever your
podcasts,
new episodes only at patrion.com/w S Y I H
pied cast.
The whole time I'm drinking the cherry pomegranate. CELSA. It's nice.
It was there all along. That's nice. Is it in front of me all along? Uh,
check out my podcast with Krista seven called Hey babe. Also on this channel,
uh, check, uh, Joker's coming out soon again and misery index season three,
we're filming that now.
And then dinner party is starting up very soon or it did start up already,
depending on when this is released,
have fun and bring these debates to your friends and subscribe.
To the YouTube, right? Subscribe to the YouTube.
Channel, YouTube channel and all the other stuff too. Yeah.
Tastes bugs. They come into the mic, talking about the food.
They hate talking about the food they like to. Fool's gonna FAPE it.
Only one food, 10 rate taste buds, man, come into them. I come shock and say,
taste good.